good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy thursday finally
now we can say it's thursday but it does
feel like it
should be a friday maybe for you because
let's just jump right in you and this
snatcher had such a crazy night last
night making news making news the
snatcher in paige snitch check her out
if you haven't seen what we're talking
about basically claudia and margo were
at zero bond last night so i was going
to zero bond before i knew that anything
was going down i was just going there
for dinner because i obviously have the
same taste and style as kim kardashian
west
as i'm in
the uber it's a members club so when you
get there like you have to be with your
member to go upstairs and i'm the member
so my friend john was like i'm here i'm
outside take your time just saw pete
davidson i'm like are you kidding
he's like no literally like there's
paparazzi outside and he was so like
nonchalant about it i'm like
was he with kim he was like no but
there's a million suvs like the street
is completely like barricaded
and i was like oh my god i'm in this cab
[ __ ] rushing
rushing to move so much traffic so slow
and i'm like [ __ ] oh my god i'm gonna
miss it then margo texts me she's like
oh i'm here with john outside waiting
for you like where are you and i'm like
i'm moving as absolutely fast as i can
and i'm just like thinking like is kim
coming or is he just going out for
dinner by himself like we didn't know
like like when kim's in town she really
does go to zero bond also yesterday we
found out that she hit up his side of
town she was spotted in staten island at
his like favorite pizza joint so if kim
was still in new york
and this is real then she would be there
obviously obviously but it was like
would they show up together like we just
didn't know and then snatcher went like
quiet in the chat for a minute i'm like
snatcher what's going on because she was
updating me
she went quiet and then all of a sudden
she sends a video of kim snatcher got
caught in the background of all these
paparazzi pics and at the end of the day
like i really don't think any of this
would have been possible without me
being late because honestly as much as i
wanted to be there which i'm sad that
i'm not in those pictures snatcher got
to see kim where it's like if it was
just a regular restaurant or if i wasn't
late we would have been upstairs eating
and once inside
kim pete and their crew did not eat in
the main dining room they were eating on
like a lower level private room
so no one really got to see them um but
i could you could 100 i know this sounds
crazy i've been to this place a million
times you could feel the energy in the
building i'm dead [ __ ] serious like
the place was on fire like it was an
electric night that's incredible and
then when we left oh by the way when i
when i actually did indeed get there
these paparazzi were like beating the
[ __ ] out of fighting with each other
like because you know they're all just
pushing each other to get in the way of
a picture and i had just missed the kim
you know hoopla and these paparazzi are
like going at it each other's throats it
was actually crazy
then when i left the paparazzi
waiting and they were also like now
people knew that they were there there
was like a million fans outside so it's
like when you see all those videos of
kim like walking from her hotel to her
car and there's like a thousand people
that's what it was got it that is crazy
so crazy and the snitch was in the
background if you guys haven't seen me
just head over to page six.com because
it's the top article snitch in the
background doing her snitchy thing and
honestly
um
what was i gonna say
oh yeah so like
i posted that i was at sierra bond last
night and i was just like
being like yeah like i'm with kim yeah
we know
i was just like really cloud chasing
and
no i didn't see them
but you were in this in the building i
was in the building and it was just
crazy like i like we our chat that we
were all texting in like knew that pete
and kim were together at zerban before
the world did and i loved knowing things
before we did and i was like just home
in bed being annoying i'm like hustle i
know which is
nothing more annoying than you could
possibly no i know i knew that i was not
in my control i was stressing you out i
was stressed out move it move it might
actually drive the space ladies was
driving miss daisy like so slow didn't
know that i have to go meet you know kim
kardashian yeah and there's only so much
you could do but i was dying a little
interesting factoid is like when kim
gets out of the car like for those
pictures to the door
they literally spent like five minutes
her security like clearing the sidewalk
like you can't pass so margo was waiting
right outside the door like where normal
person would and the guy was like are
you waiting like for an uber
and she's like no i'm waiting to inside
and they were like what can you just
like shift to the side and thank god
that he did because margo got right in
the direct line of sight right in the
direct line it was so
funny
we i wish you could have seen us when
you sent us a picture of margo on page
six we were still sitting at zero bond
screaming like we were like
like it was like the best thing that
ever happened
oh my god oh my god and everyone's
staring at us we're like you don't
understand actually it was popping
lesson you know who else was there it's
like star studded who meek mill
oh cool yeah he sat right behind me
really handsome
interesting yes it was just like a pop
in random wednesday so how was the rest
of your night i went to a drag show of
course i saw my girl izzy uncut it was
so good
um
and i just like drank and my head really
hurts but i'm not letting it affect my
performance here today
um
it was good nice to catch up with the
girly girls always nice always but i was
a good girl and i literally went to bed
so late woke up and i've fully caught up
on it on all the tv so like winter house
winter house like
how did you have time honestly
i didn't want to winter house because i
was like she's out are you [ __ ]
kidding me like she's out she's not even
gonna watch beverly hills which i
watched and then i was like i'm taking
the night off
peace
what time did you wake up okay first of
all i just want everyone to know what a
hard worker i am
i had went to dinner at 8 30 so from
like 8 to 8 20. i was late to dinner
because of this
8 to 8 20 i was watching the reunion i
literally the 15 minutes in a cab
watched on my phone spectrum tv
and then this morning i watched the rest
of it and winter house wow so i
literally care so much about the show i
can't believe i you didn't [ __ ] watch
winter especially after you guys were
like at zero bond with kim i was like
she's not watching all the tv tonight i
was like i can skip this one i could
vomit right now like pharrell wow work
hard play hard jax good for you well i
look forward to hearing your recap of
winterhouse i mean you know what i'm
actually glad you're not recapping
winter house because you like hate it
and i love it and
i was like feeling lots of feels this
episode for like certain people and i
just now i can just talk about it freely
again you don't want me to yucky your
yum yeah that's good okay cool i'll
probably catch up at some point i was
just like this isn't going to be a two
and a half hour bravo night for me i
started a new book two and a half two
plus then i watched watch what happens
live and paige and sierra we're on yeah
i like can't watch watch robin's live
anymore i always watch until the first
commercial break because that's where
anything juicy happens that's actually a
great point yeah then he starts to play
the games and the nonsense you're like
i'm good um so that's my go-to these
days plus they looked so sickening um i
didn't watch but i did see photos yeah i
saw photos too they looked sickening
the housetown yeah
um so yeah
that's really all the update for me what
about you you said you started a new
book you baked your carrot cake i know
but i ordered all the ingredients and i
ordered baking stuff on amazon because i
don't have any i don't have a cake pan i
don't have an icing thing i don't have
cooling right now it's an icing thing
you know like how on instagram like
when they spin the cake and then they
ice it with that oh like a sharp edge
yeah it's like a metal thing it's just a
metal thing yeah a scraper yeah so i got
one of those i'm hoping to have
everything in place by this weekend but
the new re episode of the redheads drop
today oh my gosh and you guys it's our
25th episode which is really crazy when
you think about it it's 25 books that's
two years or no not even two years yet
we our anniversary is in february but if
you've been there was two months where
we did two books right plus we did girl
with no job right because yeah that was
an amazing book and that's right here in
case you not in case you're not picking
let me introduce you to some of our
products we're selling here today girl
with no job.com book my memoir that's a
new york times bestselling book
and to my right to the right of that is
our canned cocktail spritz society wine
use code toast you can also hear this
use code chili and ben is literally
emailing and emailing every single
person who uses code chili which is 10
off the variety pack which is all four
flavors and sending them like this
gorgeous email with like his recipe like
you can print it and laminate it it's
really in-depth a lot of people have
been asking first chili recipe which is
my chili recipe um and if you want it
use code chili
on a variety pack so remember how um we
were saying and i was trying to explain
to you in what context were we saying
this that ben's like whole marketing
strategy is giveaways yeah what will we
say i think when i was like recapping oh
beat the crooch
beat the stupid ass
got it okay i was just like somebody
snitched on us he's like what are you
saying i'm in love with giveaways for
and i'm like i can't tell these people
anything oh my god i can't believe
that's what you're gonna snitch on yeah
okay why don't you snitch i said it to
his face i'm like you love giveaways
yeah and i've said that and also if he
doesn't know that then know thyself so i
just want to credit ben because this was
a very creative idea the chili recipe
yes code chili on a variety pack gets
you 10 off and ben's chili recipe and
i'm sorry but it's chilly season and
it's spring season so it's a perfect
symbiotic vertical integration and he
says the grapefruit pairs best with his
particular recipe interesting so new
episode of the redhead shop today 25th
episode that's 25 books so you know
we've been slow and steady this whole
time one episode a month sometimes it
doesn't feel like there's very much
redheads but we've read 25 books you
guys and the new episode is so great
whether you read the book or you didn't
we always recap the book so you can know
what we're talking about and the girls
are just we're having fun we're kicking
it we're laughing and then our dana
announces our last book of the year
which you know what i'm just going to
tell you guys what it is right now
because it this book is everywhere i
like intentionally decided i wasn't
going to read it for whatever reason
even though it's on every single list
but now i'm glad that i can check it off
the list and it's no longer like the
lingering one that i haven't read it's
called the midnight library by matt haig
it's extremely like worldwide
best-selling and it seems like there is
very danish choices so if you want to
join us it's never too late to become a
redhead it is such a rewarding community
it's such a rewarding thing to do to
like read this read a whole book
have a book club to talk about it with
and like really someone in the group is
going to have the same feelings that you
do because we never agree yesterday i
like randomly stumbled on the redheads
instagram account
and like i follow it obviously but i've
never like
dove deep into the community first of
all you have 40 000 followers like
that's a lot of people for a book club
thank you i love people in general and
the instagram is so cute i was looking
at it and i'm like look at you it's so
aesthetically pleasing and the comments
are so cute it's really just like a
fabulous corner of the internet it
really really is like it's so hamish
and it's a good place to be and i just
want everyone to know like
it's really never too late so many of
the books that we read like they're not
the most
intellectual literary confusing books
like anybody don't be intimidated join
us and if you don't understand something
again someone on these couches probably
didn't get it either and your voice will
be heard on the episode so there's that
and then also oh i did something
yesterday which people had been asking
me to do for a while and i was meaning
to do it was just laborious so at the
end of every episode of the redheads we
each give our individual rating for the
book and then we average it together and
we have our overall redheads rating in
every episode
but i never put it in the description or
anything cause i don't want to like
spoil it now every overall redheads
rating is in the description of every
episode so if you want to see if we
liked the book before you choose which
one you want to read you can just head
over
to our podcast page read the
descriptions and it's really crazy our
ratings are out of control
no rhyme or reason so insane you score
books like dancing with the stars a
hundred percent like if anyone
understands that incredibly obscure
reference no there is no it's so
listening back to what we scored some
things like
we're out of control yeah we need to do
a re-score because i agree it's also
about how a book sits with you you know
sometimes you finish your book like that
wasn't bad and then a few months later
you're like that was trash it didn't
stick with me or the opposite it didn't
make me think or the opposite so it's
just interesting redhead tings red head
tings
um
you know i'm really ready
to dive in because i've been talking a
lot and that's uncomfortable no because
i have
the worst headache okay
the room is like dancing around me maybe
you need a little hair of the dude
absolutely not absolutely not okay i'm
ready to because i didn't get a good
night's sleep last night bruno woke up
in the middle of the night and he needed
to go out he was sick but he was fine it
was all contained but like
usually he sleeps through the night so
we were up and adam couldn't go back to
sleep you couldn't or bro couldn't me
you know it's hard to wake up in the
middle of the night and get out of your
house and then like your lights are on
and your brain is awake and you have to
put it back to sleep and you took them
outside well not me exactly yeah i was
like what you did you why don't you take
zacco we he got it okay okay
okay without further ado
here are the fast life stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
pros after a pregnancy your body is
still shifting recalibrating and doing
things that don't feel normal one of the
alarming side effects of all the
hormonal changes can be excessive
shedding hair that comes out in clumps
even when you wash or brush it
thankfully we found pros to help stop
the shedding cycle and grow back your
hair pros specializes in custom hair
care and now they also make custom hair
supplements that are personally tailored
to address your specific cause of
shedding they take into account things
like hormonal changes stress level diet
and more the result is customized
supplements guaranteed to help you grow
thicker longer softer hair in record
time made with clean safe and natural
ingredients prose hair supplements are
just two capsules you take daily the
first capsule strengthens and rebalances
the scalp to reduce shedding and the
second capsule helps spark fuller faster
growth deep in the follicle try your own
custom hair supplements and you'll get
15 off today if you go to pros.com toast
that's
dot com slash toast for your free
in-depth hair consultation and 15 off
custom hair supplements yes
okay first story big news of the day big
news of the night we've talked about one
piece of it but now we need to talk
about the meat and potatoes which is
that kim kardashian and p davidson did
have a second date night in new york
city at zero bound where you know the
snatchers saw them but like these two
are
dating
yeah dating after
we wrapped yesterday tmz posted that she
went to staten island for like pizza
date night with him at like his favorite
restaurant on the roof like he'd like i
think she went to his territory and then
he came to hers because she's really she
took the ferry and then he took the
ferry
she's a zero bond girly like you like
when she comes to town that's where she
likes to go
so
this is like bigger than i could have
ever dreamed this is more than i thought
we were gonna ever get yeah i have to
say like not that i really witnessed
anything but being in the presence and
the presence the aura
of this whole thing like and it pain it
really pains me to say this like
i was kind of you know my antennas
were receiving
some like fraudulent vibes like about i
know and i don't know what's changed
okay but
so i understand what you're saying and
i've i've been seeing some things i
can't remember where i saw it probably
either like dumois or not skinny but not
that because they're the two covering on
the ground yeah on the ground here and
they were like this is really for the
hulu show they're filming this like
these dates right so that makes you
think that it's fraudulent it's getting
the day it's giving shango vibes
it's giving
shango is that his name shango are you
sure i'm positive shane lives in my head
rent-free and you don't know who that is
it's kim's body if you don't know who
that is educate yourself you know
yourself but it's kim's bodyguard from
like 10 years ago on an episode of
keeping up with shirley starts dating
her bodyguard and it's like so
fraudulent it's so cringy too everything
and we shipped so hard back then like we
would have done anything for shango to
be together with kim yeah no i like i
just need to go back to shango kim
to kardashian's hotel room and like he's
wearing the towel
claudia are you dying
[ __ ] they're like in bed together you
guys
that just unlocked like a real corner
of my brain i haven't accessed in years
so it's giving off shango vibes but then
someone else said that like pete doesn't
roll like that like he's not
one for publicity or or you know faking
relationships like pr stun so like
for that reason i'm like maybe it's not
chango
i know there's just a lot going on and i
i need to probably see the show but
they're doing great job getting us
excited for the show yeah and i'm just
excited for kim like how fun for her
again i don't think i'm not saying
they're otp i'm not even saying like
ships out to sea i'm just saying like
what a fun night she probably had last
night oh for sure
and she deserves and she deserves it
what is she doing in new york or just
filming she had that those innovator
awards oh right wall street journal and
then it seems like she extended her stay
a little bit to see her new man
yeah i mean i don't know i really do
want it to be true but i can't explain
why or how but i'm just receiving some
fraudulent
energy from this whole thing like and
that makes me sad because you know what
pete's not that guy but like kim's not
that girl she used to be but like she
doesn't need to do [ __ ] like that
anymore yeah and i do agree i love this
prospect of like i love sing okay i'm
like it you know it was obviously tough
for us to go through the divorce but
knowing that like we're gonna sit here
and talk about i'm sure this is the
first of benny like that for me is so
exciting like a new thing to talk about
we're always running out of things to
talk about yeah and i also feel like and
i probably sound like a broken record at
this point but they really could be like
working on something together and so and
they're letting they're letting the
world think that they're dating because
that's good for the show but then
they're not being fraudulent about the
fact that they're spending time together
like maybe there's something going on
that isn't romanticness what could they
be working on
i don't know
i think if anything they would be
working on is like kim has a project
coming up similar to like hosting snl
like she's doing something comedy based
and he's like teaching her like how to
be funny i don't know we're like act
yeah
but they did kiss like that's unless
we're not friends we not forget we saw
their first kiss on television it was
beautiful who knows maybe they rehearsed
it so many times oh for sure yeah oh
that probably wasn't their first you're
right because they were busy rehearsing
literally bits on bits bits on bits
that is a movie i would watch 100
kim and pete
so that's the latest with those two i'm
wishing them the best of luck best of
the best this is just such an exciting
time to be alive and i hope she stays
another night goes to another locale
i'm getting really excited for fendi
skims i don't know about anyone else
planning my buy you know she wore the
leather dress to the innovator awards it
looked so good on her it did
are you gonna buy are you gonna go for
anything of course even though like the
prices like right so you have to be
really intentional it's not like you
just will buy something
no i think if i i will go for one thing
well maybe the tights too but i don't
think the tights will be like super
expensive
um
the bomber jacket the windbreaker yeah
yeah i could take my heads out i might
go for one of those too
but i want that tight dress yeah the
turtleneck i'm just so happy for her you
know like this is a great
like kind of week to be kim yeah i mean
it's always a great week i want to know
if the collection's going to be in
stores because you might have a better
chance oh my god i have a credit
credit
yeah
but the collection is on skims.com right
it's not on
fendi like i think it's like a skims
thing
i think it's a fendi's embracing and i
was on their website and they had like a
page for it yeah so if anybody is
familiar with the
internet
in store just let us know if it's going
to be available in store that's a good
call thank you
are you ready for our next story
yeah i'm on my period i just feel like i
should say that
so that everyone knows like yeah to feel
bad for me okay and you know i was
really thinking about it last yesterday
because i was just like really having
bad cramps and feeling like it's really
unfair that like i'm going through this
right now and like ben's just like
sitting at home and at the end of the
day like it will be our child it will be
like my menstruation but it'll be our
child and i just felt this like wave of
resentment and anger that like i was
going through it and ben was just
sitting there eating a tuna sandwich
like i just thought it was disgusting of
him and i also feel like the menstrual
cycle like coming every single month is
like hella excessive i mean imagine
being pregnant and it will be our child
and i'm the one going through it and
you're eating the tuna sandwich yeah
that's true 100
but you're not getting your period right
well that's a good way to if you don't
want to get your period every month like
you could just get pregnant
yeah but that kind of thing the whole
list seems extreme
okay our next story is actually some
great news jay-z's rock nation is
hosting a job fair to help thousands of
new yorkers
newly minted rock and roll hall of famer
jay-z's company roc nation and criminal
justice advocacy organization the reform
alliance are hosting a job fair on
november 18th at madison square garden
the groups are hoping to help
disadvantaged people including single
parents and the formerly incarcerated
get work at jobs based in new york the
events sponsors said you know it's great
when celebrities are doing more things
for your community than your own mayor
like i can't live here anymore it's a
disgrace to democracy right but this is
such a great idea it says the team rock
new york job fair is a real opportunity
for socioeconomic mobility for new
yorkers those who want to work yet have
not had the exposure or connections to
the right fit jobs or to the support
services that can strengthen their pro
their prospects for employment so what
corporations such as zara lowe's madison
square garden amazon foot locker live
nation vice and 40 40 club are among
those who will be interviewing
candidates on site you know this is
fabulous you really love to see people
doing like grassroots efforts benefiting
the community lifting people up
getting them jobs and
this is a fabulous fabulous event
fabulous event fabulous idea you love to
see it you do and i just i thought this
was so awesome yes and then um
do you see jc joined instagram i did and
he's deactivated his account already he
what he didn't like what he saw i don't
think so he came to promote something it
was like a netflix film um and he's gone
already i
i feel that yeah i feel it i've seen
what i needed to say
yeah it's going to be could have like
experimented on a friend's account first
you know take the temperature didn't
have to make this whole hoopla morning
toast post about it no literally like
worldwide news and then he leaves yeah
he was only following beyonce and
honestly because
ben was looking at his instagram and i
was like who does he follow and ben was
like oh just beyonce and then i was like
why don't you do that for me
like i think that's the most romantic
thing someone could do in this day and
age behind your face be like the one
that they follow yeah yeah
i think that's like the cutest that is
really cute but that was kim and kanye
for a while but it's like it has to be
someone who really doesn't use insulin
it's not sustainable yeah like not ben
who's honest building a business
society.com code chili right code chili
um
speaking of my man
today's episode is brought to you by
manly bands after countless hours spent
jumping through jewelry store hoops in
search of the engagement ring of your
dreams the last thing your man wants to
do is run the same gamut for his wedding
band now thanks to manly bands he
doesn't have to which is truly a godsend
for brides and grooms alike manly bands
has awesome wedding bands in just about
every type of earthly material
imaginable and they even have some from
space so how it works is you'll have
your man's order the manly ring size or
from manly bands to ensure that the ring
is perfect fit
once he knows what size he is then it's
time for the fun part because manly
bands has an insane selection of
materials to choose from gold wood
antler steel dinosaur bone and even the
meteorites
he can also choose from curated
collections like the jack daniels
whiskey bauer collection i'm sure men
love that and um if he's feeling even
more creative he can customize his band
from scratch choosing the style material
you know the ma the men
in
deserve manly bands like we get all this
like glitter and like with earrings like
we don't even care you know so this is
like a fun way for them to do it and
they get to do it all from home they get
to choose whatever they want manly bands
is everything of the sword and we have
21 percent off for you plus a free
silicone ring when you go to
manlybands.com toast that's manly bands
m-a-n-l-y band
b-a-n-d-s dot com toast for 21 off the
best damn rings period manly bands it is
so hard to shop for men sometimes
especially for gifts so bookmark this
one gifts because that's a great gift
idea as we roll into holiday season have
you seen like this new movement
of people who are like november 1st
isn't holiday season like stop skipping
thanksgiving no i stay away from toxic
spaces like that yeah no because i guess
like you know last year we were all like
so excited for the holiday season it was
like a new thing to start on november
1st you know and now of course the
contrarians are coming out like what
about thanksgiving like you shouldn't
put up your christmas tree until after
thanksgiving this thing
i have so many thoughts about this first
of all what we can't be excited about
something like we're looking down on
people who are excited
for a like a season filled with joy love
family
reuniting with those you love first of
all okay so that's what we're doing and
also why can't thanksgiving have some
holiday-like elements to it why can't
your thanksgiving have a tree in the
back it should what's so wrong with that
no not only that it should and second of
all okay like i'm putting my myself in
this feet of these contrarians okay so
there are people out there who want to
put up their christmas trees
who cares like go shut the [ __ ] up get a
life like do something else yeah i mean
i think some people are definitely
imposing their views of contrarian-ness
onto others and like judging and shaming
themselves [ __ ] off but i think also
it's just like people
people are trying to like stop you know
the holidays from i think the holidays
should start at labor day that's what i
think right no and if i found out that
you had a christmas tree you know this
is a hypothetical situation where we
obviously worship christ
you had a christmas tree and you decided
to put it up in july
what am i going to do pull my hair out
like it's other people's life choices
like get the [ __ ] over it yeah you're
really stewing like thinking you're so
funny on twitter like making jokes
really because you know you're being a
loser and that other person what they're
doing enjoying the holiday fun and
enjoying their life yeah and i just i
don't understand even if i put my
christmas tree up in july doesn't mean
i'm not celebrating halloween like no
and you know what it's just like you're
putting your christmas tree up in july
like [ __ ] off no but there's just also
not like these like date this decor for
thanksgiving that you put up all month
so i think thanksgiving should really be
a fusion of fall elements and christmas
no i agree like if i had a christmas
tree and then i was like hosting a big
thanksgiving dinner
and no [ __ ] question in my mind what
i want my gorgeous holiday decor up when
i'm having my thanksgiving meal like
it's so [ __ ] stupid you wouldn't want
it up of course i would right what no
and then it's like i go through all this
work hosting all these people and then
the next day then i can put up my trade
like shut up yeah also that would mean
that you only have one month of tree in
your house and like
let's make it two
i would if i seriously if i had a trade
i would put that [ __ ] up uh six months
ago no i would never take it down truly
though like
november 1st feels like the perfect time
to get into the holiday spirit and
honestly like everyone's entitled to
their opinions but those people are
wrong and like
it's it's super grinchy
sorry it's super cringy
i don't like it
it's giving it's getting grunge it's
giving grinch it's giving shango and
it's giving scrooge get the [ __ ] out
who's scrooge
he's the scrooge of christmas what from
um you know a christmas story scrooge
he's like the og grinch is that right
yes i thought you were just making [ __ ]
up now
no a christmas story as you've never
seen it i've never seen it i never even
heard of it oh wow it's it's such like a
a common term like if you're being like
a hater you're scrooge okay well i guess
like while you've been worshipping
christ like i've been focusing on myself
and that's why i don't know what a
scrooge is
so go back to church
okay our next story is some sweet
relationship news from a couple we never
hear about devin booker is celebrating
girlfriend kendall jenner on her 26th
birthday saying she is the most
beautiful woman and i feel like all
boyfriends say that about their
girlfriends but this time you actually
the first man to actually meet it no the
first man to be factually correct
so he posted some pictures this ig story
of them sitting on an outdoor patio he
said most beautiful woman and then also
posted a picture of them hugging with a
lock emoji i think because like you know
he's locked it down yeah and they're
like locked together forever yeah and
they're so
adorable adorable in love like they've
been dating for so long now is this it
for kendall that's what i'm starting to
think like is kendall gonna get engaged
she's like she was like dating around
and she dates a lot of basketball
players so it's just like devin booker
ben simmons they're all the same like
and no this is not the same as the
previous relationships this is like a
real relationship yeah i agree i think
this could be it
hopefully they look alike by the way
which i always think
when people start dating and they look
like that means like you're sharing yeah
but also when you start dating you start
to look like
that's true but not all the time so when
it does happen
it's the right it's like owning your
dogs and their owners yes but also some
of us just naturally look like our dogs
it's so true
so i'm really happy for these two i
think they're really cute they give us
nothing and they give us absolutely
nothing when they do give us something
it's something and it's beautiful
nonetheless it is i'm appreciating these
crumbs i hope one day they'll make a
full piece of toast and you know maybe
we'll see them on the show maybe they'll
get engaged oh maybe he'll be involved
in the new hulu show i would love to see
more from these two but i mean he's busy
but maybe the success of their
relationship is in the privacy they give
us nothing they give us nothing also um
he's like
like maybe the best basketball player
like in the league right now she's not
dating like a scrub you know she's
hating like the best one oh so he's busy
with basketball tings yeah and he plays
in phoenix like i don't know how that
i i think it works well for them i guess
phoenix's like could be further yeah
they did that road trip during kobe and
they literally got their asses handed to
him which is so crazy driving in a
convertible it's just so crazy in
hindsight no i was going to be in your
own car i was writing um
my show tickets available at girl no
job.com tour
and
i was putting just this whole year in
perspective and like the things we did
and like
honestly
i don't want to say we cause i acted
normally but you guys should be ashamed
of yourselves for real like the way you
acted and like [ __ ] attacked every
single person like whose mask was
three centimeters below their nose
you should be ashamed of yourselves like
the way we all just [ __ ]
annihilated one another from our own
homes
you should be ashamed of yourself and i
really mean that never forget outdoor
family dinner
how could i i have generational trauma
from that
and it just recently came up in my time
hop and i was actually thinking about
that day
because what had happened was you know
the
someone on a facebook group had to go to
the hospital because they were so
worried about us
having dinner outside and i had fallen
asleep because we got really drunk we
hadn't seen each other in like 65 days
i got wasted
fell asleep
woke up to
i think it was over 100 text messages
and i'm like ben good morning and he's
like
good morning
and i'm like how did you sleep oh so
good yes last night was so fun
roll over
the world has apparently come to an end
and i've committed a crime right and
i was so grateful
that i fell asleep
if i had been up all night did you sleep
that night at all it kept me up and then
once i'm sleeping
i'm sleeping yeah not even the the worst
facebook group could wake me up yeah
are you ready for our next story it's
some really exciting reality tv news and
it sounds like a great idea okay joe
millionaire is set for
joe millionaire it was a show that
premiered in the early 2000s it was a
group of single women competing for a
man that they thought was made of
millions but who was actually not it was
called joe millionaire got it and now
it's coming back featuring two bachelors
one who is joe millionaire and one who's
an average joe and they don't know who's
who and they don't know who's who so
they're going to be competing you know
falling in love and wouldn't work
this will be on fox
so it's exciting for me oh so it's up
fox i guess it's gonna be bad it's
exciting for og reality tv fans because
this is like one of those shows that
like started out around the same time as
the bachelor i never even heard of it
you haven't
it was um this is where your age is
really showing i don't know if i like
watched the whole season but i like
heard of it i've heard of it yeah you
like saw the commercials yeah no i very
much grew up in the flavor of love era
um and that was a brilliant gorgeous
stunning show maybe they'll bring that
back next what do you think flavor flav
is up to oh this is so so this is the um
i'm sure he's busy with flavor too he's
good um the show followed 20 women back
in the day who were competing for the
affection of evan the contestants were
under the impression that he had
inherited a 50 million fortune but in
reality he was a working-class
construction worker if the last
contestant remaining decided to continue
a relationship with evan upon learning
the truth the couple would win a million
dollars oh so that's why they could only
do one season because then people knew
what the ruse was right so now the ruse
is different did
what are the odds that couple still
together like anything zero to zero odds
i don't know you never know you know if
they were still together they would have
a show on tlc i don't know i've never
heard of the show right but you also
don't have a great memory so and i'm
also so young
that's probably what it is my youth
is so young i don't know i might watch
this it's a funny premise yeah that is a
good idea um i'm just like all tapped
out on stupid [ __ ] shows oh okay cool
cool so are you ready for our fifth and
final story then yeah
and i'm gonna say something crazy you
don't have it in you i don't have it in
me that's okay that's okay i think it's
important to know your limit maybe i
would have it in me if i didn't have to
watch winter house i think it's
important to know your limits yeah and
to not push yourself and also you know
to not do something when you don't think
you can give it your all because then
that will affect the quality of the work
i couldn't have said it better myself
honestly our fifth and final story is
little casting news for a live action
remake of snow white gal gadot is
joining the remake as evil queen
gal gadot is in final negotiations to
portray the evil queen in disney's
upcoming live-action adaptation of snow
white a source close to the project
confirmed to variety she will star
opposite rachel zegler who's cast a snow
white she
broke out in west side story and she was
cast in june i think that we talked
about that yeah i didn't realize west
side story you know had dropped oh wait
west side story sorry i was getting
confused
within the heights what that west side
story i'm pretty sure like steven
spielberg like remade west side story
men's
or something i didn't even know that it
came out because nobody cares and
calling her the breakout star like i
mean
yeah no you could be a breakout star
maybe this will be the thing well i just
want to position it for rachel no i'm
here to talk about queen
harris
angel from god
gagadot um because i
just want to say that i was on twitter
and i was just like catching up with you
know pop culture tings because i'm a pop
culture podcast i was i don't know if
you know that and
i was
reading this tweet that announced that
she would be playing the evil queen and
i just want to say the replies
are so
[ __ ] annoying like of course she's
playing the evil one she's israeli
jewish
like you know what oh my god yeah like i
could [ __ ] choke someone so bad like
it was so frustrating it was just like
everything and all these people are mad
because i guess there was a lot of
rumors lady gaga was gonna get this role
and either she didn't get it or she
didn't want it
gag don't got it it's the one that she
got
and
everyone's just like evil israeli
you know like [ __ ] you i think
that's
a great girl she's amazing she's such a
great actress i mean you sure she did
the imagine video but like put that
aside oh wait you know what
yeah i don't know if i should really
take myself in this whole thing no but
she's like wonder woman is so amazing
she's such a great actress she's so
beautiful i mean keeping up with the
joneses was such a great movie as well
her and john hamm like
played opposite isla fisher and zach
galfinakis i don't think i've seen that
claudia
i know anybody i have a lot of things to
watch monte carlo can you start writing
these things down also i just need to
issue a correction before like
everyone's screaming at their podcast
website story hasn't come out yet it
comes out december 10th 2021 so it has
all the makings of being it has rachel
zegler as maria ansel elgort is tony
maddy ziegler's in it it is directed by
steven spielberg leonard bernstein uh
did the original score for west side
story yeah i'm like i'm pretty sure he's
dead and yeah it's like there's
literally a street named after him in
the city leonardo bernstein way
rest in peace and stephen sondheim on
the lyrics of west side story so like
this i think this could be the musical
event of the season after annie live
100
also speaking of things we want to
correct i found out some more
information about sister wise yesterday
that i just wanted to say on the podcast
but then also just explain to you two
things worth noting i'm pretty sure i'm
briefed but for everyone so mary who is
the og wife who he separated from so
that he could marry the new hot wife
part of the reason why he wanted to
marry the new hot wife is because the
new had white hot wife had two kids from
a previous marriage and he wanted to be
able to adopt them so if they were
legally married
so that answers why now why this wife
yes and then when i told you that like
all the wives have gone through their
own things like with hating cody wanting
to leave i totally forgot that at one
point mary the og wife was in an online
relationship with someone who ended up
catfishing her i saw and it was
hilarious yes and also people were
saying they are part of a sect of
mormonism like that mormons do not claim
the lisa barlows don't don't claim that
they are very uh fringe yes so thank you
for clearing that up and
yes you need to watch put it down
keeping up with the joneses
please i feel like i saw keeping up with
the joneses in theaters like i'm having
memories it's really the two couples
they live on the same street they're
like spies yeah spike things maybe uh
i'll add that to my list and they'll
also we're going to money carlo girls
monte carlo because i just learned a fun
fact you guys have seen obviously monte
carlo selena gomez
um katie cassidy from gossip girl and
leighton easter
and turns out that it was actually going
to be starring nicole kidman and it was
supposed to be like this older type of
eat pray love like like it was supposed
to be for like about older women and
then they aged it down but nicole kim
was going to be in it and someone else
i'm sure that one would have been good
yeah they should still do it there could
be many monte carlos you know it's a big
town um let's dive into the tv recap
which is uh real housewives of beverly
hills
brought to you by product that i could
desperately use right now liquid iv yes
cooler weather makes it easier to miss
signs of dehydration like overheating or
perspiration which means it's even more
important to keep your body properly
hydrated especially with flu season in
full swing proper hydration and vitamins
can help support a strong immune system
and making a making hydration a priority
helps us feel healthier on a day-to-day
basis and it fuels
us to be our best potential
and liquid iv hydrates faster and more
efficiently than water alone it contains
five essential vitamins more vitamin c
than an orange and as much potassium as
banana it's a much healthier alternative
to sugary sports drinks because it has
no artificial flavors preservatives and
less sugar than an apple they're also on
a mission to change the world they
donate have donated 4 million servings
in response to cova 19 their products
are being donated to hospitals first
responders food banks veterans active
military
um
it's
if you can't drink water like i can like
take some water and put a liquid iv in
it and it's like you drank three times
as much water it's just a light premium
life hack it's great if you're feeling
hungover dehydrated for whatever reason
um grab your favorite liquid iv flavors
nationwide at walmart or you can get 25
off when you go to liquidive.com and use
the code toast to check out so that's 25
off anything you order from the website
um promo code toast at liquid iv.com
great oh raw eh
real housewives of beverly hills part
four of the reunion finally one month
later we can close this chapter and
one month later i can say
we could have done three parts we could
have but you know what it was never
really boring i do feel like there were
some things that we circled the drain on
and even still i'm my one last question
for erica even though she has done
a plus for erica's performance she
showed up she answered the questions i
think that she
explained some things there's still some
things that you know it's up to everyone
to make up their mind do you believe her
do you not believe her
the only thing that's a lingering
question for me is the timing of her
divorce
is just if you were
what are the odds that you
fell out of love with him the same month
that he's about to like lose his entire
livelihood i just felt like last night's
episode i had she didn't say anything
new like except for that the 20 million
dollars is a lie which i like
it was in the documentary it's in l.a
times like
you can't just it's just not true like
i don't know i i mean i yeah i wish that
she clarified
how it was a lie i just felt like a lot
of what we were talking about last night
like we've heard already like and
honestly i felt the longer the
reunion went on with every minute that
passed by she was becoming more and more
unlikable like i think she came out
really strong in the first episode and
her just her like
lack of any sort of respect for any of
the women like the way she speaks to
crystal the way she speaks to sudden
like i just think she's kind of gross
and i just with every minute i was like
please get like get her off my screen i
was i hate like i hate this woman like
and i thought in part one she was doing
so good i'm like she's gonna have a
comeback but she's just like a
[ __ ] like
she called [ __ ] she called sutton
c-u-n-t yeah like she's just a awful
awful friend and you know what this
whole drama with lisa rinna like i can't
believe i used to do that trust me
someone's going to make out with brandy
glanville next season and lisa arena is
going to be the first reporter on site
lisa wren is fraudulent everyone's
fraudulent and it was a frustrating
episode because honestly these women are
[ __ ] cowards like i could just
imagine if this was happening in any
other franchise like these women are and
like literally every sutton's like the
hero sun hasn't even done anything she
has one question and erica bites your
head off she's like oh okay i totally
agree ever like i was reading on twitter
and everyone on twitter really stands
like sutton garcelle the season that's
the consensus from them but like they
were like sudden my queen you know
didn't back down she didn't say anything
she's just the only one who's not like
rolling over but the craziest thing is
that erica's whole thing is like you can
come to me you can come to me you can
come to me and then they ask a question
and they get ripped apart and these
questions aren't even
whatsoever also
erica being so pressed about sutton
insinuating that she's a liar
she said that she told a lie i mean yes
i guess that would make her a liar she
lied by omission yeah and that's she did
not share something at one point that
then she shared later that made what she
shared the first time untrue
and just this whole big reaction just
because of that
is so dramatic it's so dramatic and
isn't erica like pretty much
her cover-up is that like for the last
three years things have not been what
she's been telling us they are like okay
she's been lying for the last three
years i actually think you know erica
may or may not have done most of what
she's being accused of but i think she's
definitely a liar i think i would call
her a big fat [ __ ] liar like she
literally lied for the last three years
that he broke his ankle that tom was
fine coming over the house putting on
this play that's lying no and even in
the beginning of the season when she was
like covetous brought us so close
together we have dinner every night
we're talking to each other chicago
signing the papers crying lie right and
then you know fast forward a week before
tom's great he loves the law
next week she's leaving him no lies
everywhere so you know what she's lies
maybe like her intentions are you know
she's obfuscating the truth in order to
achieve a greater and protect herself
blah blah
but she was not telling the truth and
that makes you a liar and
i think the fact that she's like
doing backflips to prove that she's not
a liar but it's actually the one thing
she really is like
uh she she has said that literally
everything she's told us about her
marriage in the last three years has not
been truthful that's not that's a lie
yeah so this obsession with not being a
liar when it's exactly what you are is
bizarre and she's just she became
increasingly insufferable to watch like
a terrible friend a mean girl like oh
she became so unlikable and when i
thought in part one like she was killing
it i'm like oh man she's gonna come out
of this on the other side and she still
might come out of it on the other side
but i don't think people are really
gonna be able to tolerate her and the
way she's keeping score like you know
and how she's kind of whittling it down
to like you know every season you're on
the show long enough everyone's going to
go through something this is mine which
is let's not equate it to that this is
not a divorce it's a
fbi investigation like it's not it's not
it's not someone's classic like uh it's
not a puppy going into a shelter right
so i just think the way that she sees
this whole situation is so [ __ ] up
i agree and i also
but the fact that she came and answered
the questions like i don't think bravo
has grounds to fire her i think she'll
be on next year i think she already is
probably filming women and it just
highlighted for me like what a coward
i know this isn't the point of the
reading or anything but lisa vanderpump
could have done it she could have
[ __ ] shown up and answered the
questions about lucy lucy apple juicy if
erica can sit there and like defend some
of the most atrocious crimes i've ever
heard and and and tiptoe around them and
also finds
i think she
before i believe her now at the end of
part four than i did before the reading
started so i think it was a net positive
for her yeah if she could do that then
like lisa lisa vanderpump it just or
adrienne adrian not showing up because
she got divorced like and because brandi
accused her of using a certificate like
and that just made it for me like
actually you know what if you
play your cards right these things can
actually be really beneficial and they
can go away like yeah no i thought this
i had the same exact line of thinking
with lisa vanderpump and honestly for me
i feel like not showing up to reunion of
course it's a breach of contract and
they
fine you and it's but all these women in
beverly hills are so rich i get to know
but i mean you're not on the next season
no you're fired you're not a friend of
the network anymore and the fact that
lisa vanderpump like got got to break
the rules and like keep vendor pump
rules and then shoot the show on e like
that [ __ ] bothered me so much like it
still bothers me i know but at least you
know she did get fired from beverly
hills but she could have done it like
she's
she's spun way worse yeah and she it
wasn't what she was being accused of
like wasn't that crazy it was like
selling stories in hindsight obviously
you can say that now given what we've
now been watching this last season right
but she could have just
said i don't know could have been this
person but like h i i i don't know it
just made me think of that i can't lie
like i am
happy this season's over even though i
love it and i like
i i've like had enough i i am frustrated
by this season and i agree with you that
the women are cowards we make no we make
no progress because you can't ask erica
anything crystal who tried to say one
thing erica
had a dumb question and then like erica
apologizes to crystal and she's like no
it's okay it's okay yeah like like such
as backbone no literally not one person
in this group is like you are atrocious
calm the [ __ ] down like we're normal
you're being crazy like chill the [ __ ]
out no one is saying it so we're making
no progress we're just hearing her like
go back and forth on these weird stories
answering and these questions in like an
obscure way and we get no progress from
anyone or on anything yeah the only
thing i might i think everybody also
given the delilah labelle thing i
thought it was really interesting that
they brought up the munch houses thing
yesterday
i
think everybody's question and it is you
know what did erica know
and i feel like i could set maybe she
didn't know really truly yeah when we
used to talk about it i thought there
was no world in which she didn't know
but because i was like erica is a smart
cookie you know these things don't
happen she knows what's going on in her
own life she knows the person that she
married you can't pull the wool over
erica's eyes that's really what i
thought me too but now so now here's the
thing here's the lie of erica erica is
not that person if she didn't know and
tom for over a decade was this nefarious
awful person and she didn't know then
she's not the girl i thought she was and
that's the lie she came off as this
strong
she came off as this strong tough woman
and like even though she had this sort
of um
this unconventional marriage she was not
the you know just the young wife trophy
like but now she's playing that the fact
that she was giving him all of her
paychecks every single one bravo yeah
the book yeah the broadway like and
then you're you're just not the girl i
thought you that's such a good point
thanks
but again even if i was like this really
tough [ __ ] and i had a husband who was
so successful and i started making money
like i probably would
like let him manage the money because
he's obviously good with money if that
makes sense i don't know if that
necessarily
should take away from like who we
thought she was but it's a good point
yeah i mean it's not the whole thing but
like she was like
she didn't have her eyes open no and she
like really made it made it seem like
the entire time like this relationship
was unconventional but it was like a
partnership a marriage she like loved
him so much and you really got past the
fact that there were 30 years between
them like you didn't even every time i
hear how big the age difference is
differences it sounds bigger and bigger
because i'm like i don't even think of
it i never thought of it i thought they
were honestly so cute i thought that
they were equals i thought they were
partners and that's just
what we thought but it was not i thought
andy did a pretty good job i thought he
did too he was the only one pressing
he's like you're you're literally biting
everyone's heads off and you and he
pointed out like you want people to ask
you questions and and they are and
you're being evil no when he like
scoured the internet for every single
inconsistency because i don't think he
wanted any of the fans to be like why
didn't you ask this why didn't you ask
that there's nothing that he didn't ask
do you think that he
got a lot of backlash for justice for
monique and now he's being like a
well-researched host no because i heard
that in his book someone just yelled me
this that he's like doubling down on
monique
double i thought it was a book of quotes
or maybe it's the
oral history book
uh oh my god i just i just got it i just
saw this dm honestly i don't want to
know i i've had a hard day okay but
so i mean i don't want like
until he takes back and apologizes to
monique it's never gonna be the same it
will never be the same and you know what
there might only be one person who can
do it and it's nicki minaj
we'll see
we'll see
um okay winter house like you didn't
really miss anything they stayed in the
house and drank the whole time shocking
and it was like so annoying that they're
so disgusting the house is getting
dirtier and dirtier did you see the
inside of the fridge this week oh you
know i keep forgetting to look for it
but
i have to say sierra and austin are so
cute they go on like a little double
date with amanda and kyle who are like
having problems and honestly they're
really [ __ ] toxic like
they make me sad like they're
talking like you know austin and sierra
on the date they're being so cute
romantic pulling out the chair and
obviously kyle doesn't do any of that
stuff because they're engaged which is
funny like i get that but they're just
like really miserable together like i
don't know what's going on
but austin and sierra jackie are so
[ __ ] cute lindsay is like losing her
mind and this really weird thing
happened so gabby be clear she's like
i'm not interested in the new guy jason
like she likes luke and she was talking
to um
blonde girl julia about it and she was
like do you want me to talk to him for
you and she was like yeah
so it was cute
and then like julia who has a boyfriend
like she wasn't didn't do anything wrong
but and it really pissed gaby off and i
think maybe it was a little bit of an
overreaction but like she's like kind of
obsessed with luke like shake dancing
with him and just like following him
around and like nothing nefarious
but it's not a kosher no and it's not
kosher one because you have a boyfriend
and two because you literally just said
to your friend you were going to talk to
him for you it's very aaron samuels like
yeah
yes so and then it turns out they have
history like you know one of gabby's
previous relationships julia got in the
way of too so i don't we'll find out
what that is
but it was like kind of really weird of
julian like we just met her like yeah
and she
like all these new people have really
not integrated well to the group except
maybe the italian guy so it was just all
this drama from the basement you know
it was crazy i was like damn that's
really funny and i just feel like
gabby's like really struggling like
she's not having a fun time with these
people like she was on the phone with
her mom like smoking your jewel and i
was like honestly i feel so bad for you
like your jewels giving you so much
anxiety you're on this like tv house and
the drinking the drinking oh my god
amanda's like swinging from a wine
bottle at 11 in the morning does gabby
have a nice room at least yes and you
know i was actually taking a look at the
ribs you know who's the nicest friend
who's a king bed to himself
andrea andrea what's his name andrea
yeah
he's a sickening room and you know what
paige and sierra like they really need
to clean up their room like it's also
interesting to see who makes their bed
and who does not austin makes his bed
and that's why i love him i love him so
[ __ ] cute and craig is just like
falling between the cracks like trying
to call his girlfriend there's no phone
service like
he's kind of like giving me nothing damn
damn damn damn especially because craig
and paige are
going so strong i love them they're such
a funny couple really honestly an odd
match
at first
they seem like an obvious match you know
they're just like both good looking
whatever on the outside but craig is
like goofy right that's exactly what i
was gonna say craig is so groofy and
paige is like high fashion new york city
like socialized girly like she's she's
just um
i i think he must be like he intimidated
by her like i would i'm intimidated
but like but then they you know found
love no it's so cute but it's just i
didn't think when i see pictures of them
together i'm like oh these are kind of
like um opposites 100 but i didn't
realize and i don't think in present
time sierra and austin like are anything
which is making me so sad because i
think they might be she said she's
single they're so they're cute on the
show jackie like okay but i just want to
say um when they were on when he was on
watch what happens live even though
lindsay was there and now like lindsay's
taking a break from austin's friendship
even though she was with him a week ago
he would not he like only had flattering
things to say about sierra they played
this game where they had they pitted
like lindsay and sierra against each
other because about travis is so [ __ ]
and he still wouldn't say anything bad
anything negative about sierra said like
the nicest things about her and if
you're saying they're so cute like i
feel like there's a chance they could be
together
imagine paige and craig austin and
sierra like all going down
jackie it's so [ __ ] cute and i kind
of love how like paige and sierra are
becoming like this duo it was always
paige and hannah um
and actually i wanted to listen to them
on call or daddy because apparently they
go into like in the fact like
hannah not filming anymore is like so
good for paige because like paige was
constantly caught in like hannah's her
best friend but she's also the most
toxic person on the show like where do i
go from here and like how do i film with
people who like hannah hates like and
it's actually been like good for them
yeah will you listen and give us the um
i just like hate listening to podcasts i
know but maybe do it while you get ready
tomorrow morning yeah
i will um because i actually really want
to hear and i think there's like some
some tea there and i think they they
from what i heard that they haven't like
really addressed it between each other
so that's a lot but no like sierra and
paige are like this dynamic duo like of
girly girls like socialites paige is a
duo kind of girl she is and but i kind
of get that especially when you're in a
new situation like it's just so good to
have a buddy
like you're then you're just you're fine
yeah so i thought it was a cute episode
i mean like
the stockholm syndrome is there like i
don't know how long we can watch the
show where like
thankfully towards the end of the
episode somebody started cleaning the
kitchen luke was vacuuming and i think
gabby or julia was doing the dishes it
was i was very grateful for it because
that one area that little dining room
and the kitchen is so vile and it's
small that's a small kid it's a small
house
i mean there are so many bedrooms but
like the common areas are not
are not large large and there aren't
many
yeah no it definitely stresses me out
yeah i just also don't really like this
guy andrea like paycheck really wants
[ __ ] but she's like once i do like
he'll lose interest in me she's really
smart
and i don't like knowing that the
possibility of craig is out there like i
can't watch her like date this italian
man who means nothing to me and didn't
in this episode he's like texting other
girls
oh you know what i didn't want to last
eight minutes so maybe it was in there
but it wasn't anywhere else interesting
because that was the in the previews
yeah
okay maybe it'll be like the end of this
episode beginning of next episode tv
continued yeah well i hope she gets over
him because like
craig is waiting she's too good for that
100 it's just so like so obvious you
know like be more creative page like
she'll get she gets that craig is the
creative choice like because he's the
full package in my opinion yeah but it's
nice imagine how it was moved to
charleston and then did
southern charm and summer house like
they would vacation this summer in
hamptons yeah no but craig and paige
like started us as friends clearly which
is a great foundation for a relationship
i think that
because like they couldn't be together
in a romantic way on the show because he
had a girlfriend and i don't think he
ever cheated on the girlfriend maybe
that looks good to paige
i think that it gives them the makings
of like an actual strong relationship
not just like
we hooked up on the show and we're gonna
keep dating no like they didn't even
hook up on the show i don't think so we
just love each other so much
okay so that is your winter house real
housewives beverly hills recap and that
is your show i'm actually feeling so
much better like the show always makes
me feel better toast is curative it is i
hope this was curative whatever you're
going through
and if it's not check out the redheads
thank you so much for listening to the
morning toast millennium morning show
where we deliver the past life stories
that you need to know every monday
through friday on youtube so if you're
giving
what so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up for us
available as podcasts and where podcasts
can be found so it's about our itunes
digital public radio i already know all
the places champions and podcasts find
us this morning toast sleeping five star
review about our beautiful stunning and
smart we are
you want to take that much you think
hmm what emoji for today
could have possibly
because we're standing in solidarity
with our november first sisters
christmas tree we're standing in
solidarity i love that claudia that's
beautiful thank you guys we'll see you
tomorrow get my book
pittsburgh society and my tickets to my
tour girlsnojob.com
new episode peace out